welcome everybody to another business QA
while we play league of legends I am
excited to be back I missed yesterday I
was recording my audio book sorry guys
we did our gratitude live stream but
didn't have time to do this so i
finished the audiobook that's the good
news and i am back in the saddle with
the screaming we should get to me what
can we shoot you I got excited there
Evan I'm really excited for you and I
know this is a lot of people and believe
nation are anxiously awaiting this
audiobook so and you know Evan I don't
really listen to audio books but for you
I'm gonna get this audiobook because I
cannot wait to hear you read it what
just happened with j reyez oh you
cancelled and we're back in okay we're
back in I don't know what happened there
yeah me too like I would I don't I don't
listen audio books but I would listen to
my aati it's good it's so our anywhere I
mean everything is good you know what
like I would consume went as you can see
what if you guys like audio listen audio
if you like reading read it it was great
because when I wrote the book it was a
lot of chunks and sections like I would
write one section and then take a break
and come back with another section with
this I was forced to go through the
whole thing and it just dawns on me how
powerful it is i'm so pumped anyway um
yeah i was i was there was there was a
lot of energy that was brought to the
recording studio yesterday to to do this
audiobook so yes but i'm excited to be
back here with you guys i have my usual
game partner Jay rise in the house to
we're trying to get a game going Rishi
what is in the cup today yes I've got my
my hazelnut coffee today which I love
trying to think right now what the brand
is so but i can't remember cuz it's been
Oh see ya yeah Seattle I'm new to the
seattle coffee brand someone new there
hazelnut is quite delicious this is not
a sponsor to add or anything
but it's quite good and and then I've
got today just a cup of determination
comin Wow yeah I want to miss it I like
that I like the cup of the termination I
feel like you need to start doing coffee
reviews or in the YouTube channel or
something to get sir getting sponsored
by these guys no kidding cut um I will
say those I am officially a business
kind of fun I am officially an affiliate
or that cups app that I told you about
Joe so you know it's it's uh not a like
a full-on brandeal but whenever i get my
affiliate link if anybody wants to try
out the cups app I will absolutely make
sure you guys can get discount off your
coffee and all kinds of fun stuff well
wish you had a big video on her channel
about coffee national coffee day and
krispy kreme so coffee love out there is
that the video that you watched recently
that's funny i watch that I watched your
song in part of the live stream oh that
was fun cool thanks for watching Evan
that's always really cool what's in oh I
have to know kick it my nena bought me
some yogi tea again so I'm having my
lemon tea and the quote of the day here
is the art of happiness is to serve all
so I'm liking that I'm feeling the yogi
Oh feeling a yogi tea I'm going to a so
I got I got jungle here which I'm
excited about and I'm going to a I going
to a mix of an old strategy with a new
strategy saying I try something a little
bit different today so we'll see we'll
see how it goes um before we get started
let's give some shoutouts people
watching a live chat rise online
obviously Zeno gen so much who's
probably pretty familiar with seattle
coffee coke glass the master 57 did it
get everybody soul forged
Opta sourcebook you guys are all
chatting I love it that's great hey you
know what when we started this nobody
was watching 00 Watchers but i like it
we're building it up okay lonely we're
getting into a game looks like Jay rises
trying to do rise oh did we talked about
this already right does a champion in
the game called rise yeah right okay
good so he looks like he's trying to
play rise Jay rise is going to be on
rise and there was someone in the chat
was asking about is this game looking
for the comment now is this game like
open for other people to play I just
trying to find it but yeah I I think
that we've had people come in the chat
and then end up playing with you right
yeah if you add me on believe team now
chief you're on the North American
server believe team yeah we've done it a
couple times um trainer six chain or six
was another class that we've had on a
couple times he was a hyper-aggressive
ATK was five it was fun so yeah just I'm
yeah I'm will do it it's too late for
this game before the first maybe for
tomorrow okay are you going to UM take
the advice to from trauma Louie was it
Louie they gave you the advice what if i
said Louie give me about pink o people
are having it with someone else my coach
Martin yeah your coach Martin Oh what
about Louise not my god it was a friend
Martin is my coach yeah I gotta remember
you know what a good little uh you could
check in with me in about 10 minutes hey
did you buy the pink ward did you buy
the pink ok yeah I will check in okay
all right let's do it let's get some
questions going you're ready yeah cool
alright so first question is coming from
Teresa and Teresa says I'm an MBA
student and working towards the
dissertation I'm really struggling with
the topic and asking for help so she has
two topics she kind of goes into and in
lengthen in detail but essentially it's
coming down to a topic around women as
leaders uh or she's also thinking about
a topic in IT in the health sector she
was in Zimbabwe recently for a business
trip and she monitored the sites of
these rural hospitals and she found that
they had like they were in such deep
need so she is kind of interested in
also providing value through kind of
meeting the needs there so she said I
look forward to your comments and also
suggest topics in HR and IT okay so
she's writing a dissertation that's what
this is for exactly and she kind of
wanted your thoughts feedback about a
topic obviously for those who don't know
when you're writing your dissertation
it's quite a lengthy thesis that you
complete for your education and it can
guide your career trajectory trajectory
from there on so it is a big deal
sometimes you know how to pick these
topics okay let's do it ah what you got
okay this is some advice hi well you
know it's interesting because of course
you know no one at the end of the day
can tell you what the best topic is
going to be because it's you know
there's so many there's value you can
provide for both I mean I think it is a
hot topic right now for sure women
leaders women in business that's like
obviously more trendy topic right now so
I could see why that would be appealing
but also it sounded from from the way
that she talked about the needs that she
was seeing in her trip to Zimbabwe it
seemed like she cut
this is this is just me based on seeing
all that she wrote in this email seemed
like she kind of got passionate about
finding ways of meeting the needs for
the lack of IT and in the health sector
there in Zimbabwe so I think maybe
there's two things I would just ask
yourself is like what what is something
that you could see yourself in the long
term being passionate about you know it
might be exciting to talk about a
particular topic now but will you can
you see yourself investing in this as a
career as a expert five years down the
road this is something you'd still want
to be kind of establishing yourself as
an expert in this particular area and I
know that you may not have those answers
all right away but I think it is
important to think like more long term
and it seems like you were really
passionate about it when you saw the
need and I will say I just keep seeing
Stephen Kelly I follow him closely on
Twitter and he there just seems to be so
many exciting things happening in
particular in Africa in terms of
business in IT and I don't know so that
is an interest definitely seems like
it's an area there's a lot of need and
there's a lot of attention right now for
so I don't know just I think I think I
think that the second idea sounded the
one like she was most excited about and
so that definitely is significant I
think cool uh big decisions with the
heart small ones with the head it's boom
it's just another example of that you
know like the worst thing you could do
is do it do a topic on technology that I
think is great
yeah like you know what you know what's
super rapidly growing and has a huge
base league of legends go do a topic on
Lincoln legends right it's the worst
thing you could do because if you don't
have a passion for it it's going to be a
crappy paper where I what I love from
her is the wanting to make a difference
wanted to do something important wanting
to have wanted to write a paper that you
know really mean something to her Wow my
team just totally left me up to dry
there that was not cool Wow guys way to
put your jungler behind all right anyway
whatever um I get that she's like really
mission-driven and so what you want to
do is make sure that whatever you're
writing about is something that you are
deeply deeply passionate about if you
love to topics I would try to look at
combining them i love i love the end i
love trying to find a way to make both
work so can you make the you know can
you profile women leaders in africa as
an example that's something that's you
super passionate about and if not then
pick the one that pick the one that you
feel the most even if it may not make
the most sense that's it sits for
everything else like what business
should I start well it's the one that
you're most passionate about you can
have success in any business you could
be sexual you can be successful in as a
league of legends gamer you could be
successful you know making shoes you can
be successful as a singer and you can be
successful anything but the the critical
component to success is the love for the
work not the nut not whatever work not
whatever work it is right it doesn't
matter what the industry is you can have
success anywhere and so that's what I
would say that make sure you're picking
the the paper topic that makes you most
excited whatever that is
it's it home yeah and I just kind of a
follow-up question you know I've heard
people like Martha Stewart say you know
go find out what the customer needs and
build your business around that but it
sounds too like Martha Stewart was also
extremely passionate about that industry
so is he countering that advice or is it
that if it is it having the passion and
building around the needs of the
customer yes boo me edict except it's
good you look at you look at Martha
Stewart she started her her catering
business out of her out of her kitchen
like she just had a passion for and she
wanted to turn into something it's it's
both because it's because there's two
elements to what I'm saying there's big
decisions with the hard and small ones
with that head right and so that's why
it's both because when you decide I'm
going to go into catering right she was
a model and since you want to go in the
catering okay I'm gonna get into
catering great that's the decision you
make with your heart how do I do it how
do i execute how do I find the right
food you know how do I learn the right
skills how do i be a good hostess how do
I you know educate my customers all of
those things are the head decisions and
if you flip the order then you're not
going to have success so as an example
since you're watching videos use my
youtube channel you know I make videos
that I'm passionate about right i make
videos that i want to make a video on if
i don't have a message to share with the
video then I don't make the video
there's somebody that we can't profile
or I don't really you know like their
story or whatever if I'm not passion
about the video doesn't get released now
once i do have the vote jay is fighting
can go
j so i make videos based on the heart
now once in videos out I use my head
because I need to think about what am I
going to call the video so that it gets
attention you know what am I going to
use in the title in the description and
the tags and the thumbnail right all of
those things become super important but
if I started with the head and only did
market research what would I do I would
look at ok one of the most popular
YouTube videos out there now and it's
going to be stupid cat videos or you
know prank videos or you know so a lot
of people do this so this is why it's
important right I'm going to have to I
want to have success on YouTube so I'm
going to go and look at what's popular
and just model that ok great the problem
is I can't make stupid cat videos I
don't like cats I'm really not a cat
person and because i don't have the
passion for cats and making these videos
the most i'll do is only is it just is
mediocre i'll never make anything great
and so i might make a few bucks but I
could I could make way more and have a
way bigger impact somewhere else and I
think that's a chap most people fall
into those big decisions starts with
your heart and then you use your head to
figure out how to actually get it done I
love that that's what are you practical
application cool all right well good
luck to you Theresa next question comes
from marcin i bought my pants just so
you know i bought the pink architected i
failed a ten-minute a reminder live in
10 minutes I don't know I don't know
what I bought the pink so either way
good for you good for ya slowly
remembering oh we got a comment in the
in the chat de Massa no cat LOL
yeah I feel you I'm not a cat person I'm
not a cat person either or no offense to
you guys to our cat lovers this doesn't
not my thing either okay all right next
question comes borama oh I said this
already Munson Munson says I had a quick
question I have prototyped an amazing
and truly unique app that people all
around the world we use every day it
will help them connect find jobs expand
business selfing seek something
incredible capability unlike anything on
the market I've made a nice prototype
and I'm wondering what shot i have and
what kind of deal i could expect if one
of the people like for example mark
cuban would have liked it from the
beginning if it needs to be developed
based on my wire frame prototype am i
only looking at typical licensing deal
or can i expect something else are you
willing to check it out and partner up
with me on this look forward to hearing
from you thanks in advance already so
cool exciting you have an app that it
sounds like you've done enough of your
own homework on your end to realize that
it's it's unique and it's different and
sounds like you feel like it's a real
value obviously that's it kind of the
first step that we always say with app
right is make sure the app is great if
it's not great and don't try to even do
the other stuff because you should want
to provide something that your users are
going to love so that's kind of like the
first step and then the second step
which is kind of cool we talk a lot
about influencers and getting them to
check out the app and how that will
obviously be super helpful you know I
don't know if you have a connection to
mark
even I don't know how you would plan to
connect with him or anyone else for that
matter that's an influencer but
obviously that would be hugely important
I mean would it be hugely helpful but I
don't know that it's necessary but if
you have access to someone who who
believes in it then yeah obviously
that's gonna be a game-changer ah so
yeah and then in terms of licensing evan
i'm going to i don't know that the
nuances of of the licensing or app so
all right well the first question i
thought was what kind of deal can i
expect to get from this and the deal
that you can expect to get for a wire
frame is zero nobody's going to buy a
wireframe even a fully developed app is
almost zero because it's so easy to
create apps these days mark and when is
not interested in wireframe and is not
interested in a fully developed app that
has no traction what you need if you
want to get somebody on board you need
an app and you need traction you need
momentum you need customers you need
people who are leaving out paying for it
that's fine but they need to see that
there's a user base and that people are
logging in every single day because they
love your app and so it's great that you
love your idea I'm you know super happy
for you you've got to do more work then
you've got to get it there and make it
you got to make the app and then you
need to market it we covered it a couple
times how to market a nap I have some
videos on it too but I mean looks like
you're not even ready for that yet
because you don't have the app but
investors don't want to buy a concept
especially an app concept
they don't want to buy something that
has just been developed but has no
traction on it so that's the that's the
sad state of of entrepreneurship but
also kind of important because it helps
separate you from everybody else when I
was in a venture capital business I saw
so many companies come with just an idea
and the idea is not enough unless you
have a patent and unless it's easy to
see the path to success because the
corporation wants to buy you know
whatever it is that you have then the
idea is not enough you need to execute
on it now hopefully you have the skills
to do it if you have the ability to
wireframe I'd hopefully have the ability
to program it if you don't then you need
to partner up with somebody who can help
you with it that's a that's the honest
truth and I don't want you wasting time
on the wrong thing when you could be
doing it building this building this
thing up soon so good luck good luck I
feel like good luck is sound so bad
you're going to be great work really
hard and it is going to be great I'm
sorry okay um I like that extra extra
love for me she there well people use
because like I know you really meant to
definition but some people say good luck
like good luck like yeah alright that's
not gonna work but that's not how I know
we meant it all right yeah and I mean
it's also message to everybody else out
there who is trying to do something
similar people think that if you know an
investor is going to save them no
investor wants to come on and do this
like if you're an investor you have tons
of options they're gonna want to work
with somebody who's further ahead so go
and get further ahead there's a lot of
companies there's a lot of people who
have apps who have traction who have an
audience already and they're still not
getting deals the deals that they want
and they still are just working hard or
building a bigger audience building up
more acceptance building up more
momentum meet that yeah so before we go
on the next question looking at the
chest the lots of chatter actually
seemed to triggered a lot of chatter cat
cats conversations still kind of going
on um and all right I think that yeah I
think I'm caught it their mamas are
questions over there did I miss it um
you know there was a question that I
don't know if you're talking about the
question from Colt glass but i think
that question he was just addressing he
or she was addressing to the the people
in the chat so all right all right um
next question comes from khyati joshi
and yes khyati juice Josie khyati Joe
she says hello sir myself Tod Joshi
thank you so much for the advice sir
that really meant a lot here I'm asking
my next question as I thought of doing
social entrepreneurship I really want to
do it but music is my passion and I am
learning Indian classical music I'm in a
confusion that would social unturned I'm
in a confusion I think yeah there is
kind of torn between his passion for
music and thinking that he also you know
wants to do social entrepreneurship I
guess this comes back down to what we
started with in the top of the chat is
like the big decisions with the heart
and small decisions with the head and
realizing to I mean it's interesting
because I know pick any classical I was
going to say can you do both you know
because there's lots of people who are
interested in both and find a way to
combine but I Indian classical music if
I'm understanding what he was thinking
of doing can require like intense
rigorous dedication discipline and you
know it's not like something you're
doing as a hobby you're like training
sometimes seven eight hours a day to
perfect it so I don't know if that's the
best advice to try to do both because it
might be something like you have to be
all in on but as the musician myself
like I could never not do it you know
and if that's a passion of yours it
would be definitely a mistake to to not
do it so anything that you can do to
make your passion happen is it is a good
thing and then the same thing with
social entrepreneurship like it's not a
right or wrong it's just do you do you
love it enough and feel much a
passionate enough about it that you
could really dedicate your life to it so
all right um we're kind of in a fight
here so I'm Jay and I are trying to do
some damage we're doing some work don't
know how successful we're doing we all
ready yet but we're working on it um
it's honestly similar by so I loved it I
loved the answer like my instinct always
just try to do both if you have two deep
passions I think that's where most
people have most of the really
successful people they don't just do it
the same way everybody else does it they
do it their own way they find their own
little angle on it and so to me those
two things don't seem like they're in
totally different worlds you could
do music with a social angle like the
songs that you sing about could have a
social message right I mean why is you
to you too so successful you don't think
they turn their they turn their passion
for social good and social justice and
pour it into their music and then that
leads to business ventures that they're
working on so I would try to see if I
could combine if it's so strict that you
can like you can't pick the topic that
you sing about you can't pick where
you're sinning and you know the
organization that you're doing then
maybe but I you know I would try to find
a way to make that music be more
meaningful to you I picked this away I
didn't know I feel this away but even if
it's just picking glad that the the the
type of song like what are you singing
about what what's the main message of
your song right you should have a
message if you want art to be you want
your art to take off it's got to make
people feel something so what are you
trying to make people feel through your
message there's got to be something so
why can't that message me something of
social good just like a business like if
you're starting the business just trying
to make money you're gonna you're not
going to do very well or go very far you
have to be on some kind of mission and
the way you execute that mission is
through you know the products and
services that you create which is great
so you're here creating music it's got
to be for a reason it's got to be a for
reason other than just trying to make a
career for yourself
so yeah I'll try to find a way to do
both yeah and I think it kind of reminds
me of the we have someone asking about
lipstick wanting to do modeling and a
lipstick line and you know sometimes
it's important to focus on one because
putting all in on one it's not it means
you're not saying no to the other but
one you have to start with and focus on
and then you can build toward the other
and so I'm going to use my brother's an
example here this is like definitely a
pleasure for my brother who truly like I
think of who's doing both like it's not
just about the music it's a powerful
social message as well but he started
with the insane dedication to the
discipline of music and that has now
opened up doors for his message and so
with the lipstick line we were talking
about how you can remember once someone
was like modeling or lipstick and it's
like okay start with one and you can
build a build a brand which will open
doors for the other thing so I like I
don't know that I thought of that when
you said think about your message of
your music because you could be really
dedicated to music and that it opens the
door for the message on a broader scale
yeah yes I agree we're in the middle of
a fight here so I'm kind of concentrated
on both but I think in this case the
thing that comes to mind is that it's
not that but you there's an easier way
to combine the two it's not it's not so
difficult to do them unless I'm missing
something you know which could be the
case 2 i'm not i'm not a fish annatto or
connoisseur of indian music so i
couldn't tell you but the idea of doing
something social
you know like it really bothers me when
people feel like they have to do a
non-profit to do good work like should I
start a business or should I do a
non-profit because I really have this
social cause that I care about well do
both you could do both you can like you
want to have success in business and
have a social cause it's so important it
doesn't have to be one or the other so I
think in this case it shouldn't be that
difficult to do both and I think I think
I think ultimately there'd be a lot
happier if they could yeah so now I'm
sure what you're saying you're also
saying don't necessarily assume that the
social entrepreneurship has to be a
non-profit it can be you just doing your
thing and making up impact to do that
thing yeah and understanding if if you
can take parallel paths like if it makes
set to do it at the same time or if
you're just going to if it's a path that
one leads to the other right like the
lipstick one might be the case of one
leads to the other right yea Timo
getting kills but aim t9 team is dying
but team oh well what else is new GMO
getting kills with team is dying yeah so
the modeling into lipstick yeah you
could do both at the same time um it
just may mean that nothing gets done
where if you're singing you need to have
a message anyway so why not make it a
message that is important to you where
you can feel like you can bring that
social entrepreneurship or social
message and mission in
yeah yeah I mean we even kind of talked
about this last night on when you were
messaging me or on in our mastermind
about the feedback for the YouTube
channel we've got you know a lot of
different series going on oh my god it
either can work you can do all the
series at the same time but then you
only have a month in between so the
practice time is limited so you can't do
as much you know your growth in each one
won't be as much but you'll grow on all
of them slowly so where's the trade-off
what's what's the balance for you that
makes the most sense mmhmm yeah and I'm
one of those people who as much as I
love music I will never be fully
fulfilled if I'm only doing you just
like I have to do all these things sure
so I don't know if what's in my cup
alrighty alright so thanks for the
question piaggio joshi i hope that that
help you how you doing heaven you ready
for the next one yeah I'm ready I'm
ready I'm ready I'm gonna go back and go
back to base get some items okay old I
am ready do we have that already the
next question comes from charlie and
Charlie yeah Charlie asked hi I'm a
university student looking to start my
own business the major problem i am
facing it did we lose Rishi
did she mewed herself they did it mean
to try okay hold on try this for myself
you cut out for a whole chunk of that
hello yeah there we go I missed I missed
the whole chunk of that what was
happening to me okay I got Charlie from
University that's it ok cool so Charlie
ass hi I'm a university student looking
to start my own business a major problem
i am facing this time the fact that my
country is facing economic problems
right now has motivated me to try this
for myself I was hoping you could advise
me on the best way to avoid getting my
ideas stolen while looking for investors
so I'm hearing him say there's a problem
with time and then there's a question
about ideas things going with investors
so I think the first thing I would just
say is I wish I knew why you felt time
is not on your side I mean we start when
we start and it sounds like you're ready
and and so if you're ready just go for
it but since you are at the start like I
wouldn't be thinking about investors at
this stage because there's no need for
that when you're just starting out and
in the potential investors aren't going
to be interested in this stage of the
business so I think the main focus right
now should be not worrying about the
time issue just start and basically just
you know put all your love and hustle
into the value that you're looking to
provide as a as a small business and
learn as much as you can
I mean watch as much video here on Evans
channel I mean there's so much great
information for anyone who just want the
star and but yeah I wouldn't even go
into the investor area at this stage all
right well my team decided to surrender
so that's not great um that's a bummer
yeah it's okay um what I love me I love
the mines in at the start of this
question where it was uh nothing about
the you know my kid my country's economy
sucks so I want to do something about it
and I want to be an entrepreneur
something like that which I love because
a lot of people take the other approach
I won't be successful because I'm in
this country and our economy sucks right
to understanding about investors is
important one you know doing your work
on the doing your work on the due
diligence of investor the good investors
don't like they're not in the business
of just stealing ideas they want to run
it likely i would get that all the time
as a venture capitalist like I don't
want a run company I don't want to
started I don't want to start your
business you're the expert in you know
sewage or whatever it is you're coming
to it you I have no intention of
starting a sewage business and no you're
you being so defensive around it means
that I can't help you because you can't
share your idea most men won't sign
non-disclosure agreements because did
you see too many of the same ideas I'll
see too many of the same ideas over and
over and over and over again and it's
just not it's not something I then sign
over and on the screen jerk is and you
can't do work with the other companies
but with all that being said it's still
like your time right now should not be
spent if you only have an idea you
should be out making it happen not
trying to find investors you have to
balance where you're putting your time
putting your time into trying to seek
investment where it's an insanely low
chance you're going to get it versus
actually
building a company where the more
momentum you build the more easy it's
going to be to get the money to grow I
would be hyper focused on building
something that I can get some traction
with maybe that means just start smaller
maybe you don't get the half a million
or hundred thousand or 5000 or whatever
it is you think you need to start just
start smaller start building up some
momentum because any investor who will
come in at this point is going to take
so much of your company that it's not
going to worth it for you because you
haven't done enough work yet right like
an idea is not enough you got to go and
execute the idea so for people who just
want to get paid for their ideas again
unless unless you have a patent on it
unless it's and and there's an easy fit
to see how a company needs this you
don't get paid just from your ideas you
know I have a I have a million ideas for
McDonald's I could walk into my doctor
to give a million things that they could
do better but that doesn't mean
McDonald's gonna pay me so you gotta go
and actually start doing it build some
momentum get some traction get some
users or customers get some media
attention start building something out
so that you have something of substance
so then when you actually go to
investors you have a lot more to your
business and it's a lot easier to get a
yes out of them thanks what I got I feel
like there's a question let me go back
no did I miss a question yeah there's a
lot of chatter I I did ask them if I
missed something and they said no no oh
here book fish yeah it's near the top
book fish 35 said I think this is a
weird question but I would love some
someone's point of view if I'm starting
out as an independent author can I
consider myself an entrepreneur even
though I have booked contracts with
publishers that was near the top I only
saw the top does the other time yeah
yeah that was the question he was asking
just kind of like I'm glad that you went
back to it because if you want I think
it'd be great to hear your feedback as
well I think he thought it was a
little bit of a question that he just
wanted to get some he wasn't sure it was
a good question for the lives uh yeah
but I think it's a great question so
what do you think so the question is how
do you think I'm trying to find it so I
can make sure on that Oh at the top
right starting out as an independent
author can I consider myself an
entrepreneur yeah why I I mean I love I
for me as an artist you know I didn't
think of myself as an entrepreneur
initially but I mean as long as you are
I think the real definition of an
entrepreneur is when you provide and Val
you provide value to the world and and
then I awesome byproduct of that is that
you can also you know build a business
from it so why would an independent
author be excluded from that yeah and I
think just don't don't don't get so
attached to labels you know who cares if
you think you're an entrepreneur then
didn't own it you're an entrepreneur
right what I sign up to me or reach here
or anybody in the chat to tell you what
you label yourself as and I think just
caring less about the opinions of other
people and just whatever you want to
call yourself go and do it yeah I think
embracing the attitude of an
entrepreneur can help even if you're not
an entrepreneur I think the you know I
think of worse if I think of
entrepreneurship what does an
entrepreneur mean to me I think about
somebody who's resourceful somebody
who's creative somebody who finds a way
to get stuff done somebody who wants to
have a positive impact somewhere you
know you can apply those things to
anything you can apply that even if you
have a nine-to-five job when you're
working at a company you can find to be
more resourceful and how you
get your work done you can work at a
company that is having a mission and you
feel like you're important part of it
you can come up with creative ideas to
further that mission you know even if
you're just working 9-5 that's why a lot
of people watch this channel while they
have jobs they have no intention of
becoming an entrepreneur because the
message is still applicable well so I
don't know what the resistance is if
it's just fear of judgment you know do
you want to call yourself a creative you
want to call yourself an author you want
you know a lot of people I am I author I
haven't written the book yet well have
you know if you write like who cares
it's what did you consider yourself an
author have you written a tweet are you
enough for now you know I wouldn't worry
so much like I worry more about getting
great work done right poor that poor
that energy and mental thought into
making a great book and promoting it and
getting getting the impact that you want
out there as opposed to worrying what
you call yourself for what other people
call you that's that thanks for the
question I love it live chat I love the
live questions alright well I did the
best on my team but couldn't pull out
this victory I'll continue the
experiment next time though I think I
think it was a viable experiment thank
you guys for watching Rishi the message
of the day you're going to leave us with
today is who care couples who cares what
what other people say you are or not
what do you believe that you are I love
it couple who cares what other people
think that's a long it's a long cup of
but I like typing that out with a
hashtag cup of who cares what other
people think but I like it good thank
you guys for watching uh this is it for
today I'll see you guys again tomorrow
morning for the gratitude strain to
League of Legends stream continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
we'll see you tomorrow